and finally new rule since this is
Mother's Day weekend let's pause and
take a moment to think about how your
mother was always there for you looking
after you and keeping you safe and then
realize that's not Twitter's job
keeping you safe and sorting out the
lies from the truth is your job
when we talk about misinformation we
always focus on the producers never the
consumers as if we're all helpless dumb
blondes ready to believe anything like
Donald Trump
foreign
[Applause]
do lies spread faster than they used to
of course but so can truth which in the
internet age is always at your
fingertips you just have to learn how to
use Google for something other than porn
but this idea that we can clean up
Twitter and protect you from fake news
and disinformation it's so ridiculous
it's like fact checking the graffiti on
the bathroom wall of a dive bar
[Applause]
we called this number and we didn't have
a good time
people always lie that's what people do
every age is the misinformation age and
whenever a new means of communication
comes along some reach right for the
sensor button in 1858 the New York Times
thought we couldn't handle the
transatlantic Telegraph they said it was
superficial and too fast for the truth
in 1487 the pope issued an order to stop
the misuse of the printing press for the
distribution of pernicious writing you
know fake news
like how the Earth is a ball
[Laughter]
in 1938 radio was the hot medium of the
day and lots of people got plenty worked
up about it especially after Orson
Welles presented what was obviously a
fictitious drama about a martian
invasion of New Jersey and thousands of
people thought it was real and panicked
you cannot censor away that level of
naivete the Martians had the whole
universe to invade and they chose New
Jersey
[Applause]
people on social media like to say I did
my research but it doesn't count if you
did your research on social media
I once did a stand-up special called be
more cynical this is what I was talking
about
lies are ubiquitous and in that way
they're quite analogous to germs and
viruses people think you can germ proof
the world and never have to be in
contact with the things that can hurt
you but you can't you have to have a
strong immune system it's the reason
babies who live in sterile environments
are more likely to develop allergies
than babies you're allowed to exist in
the world as it is messy and impure lies
are all around you develop a better
[ __ ] detector that's a better
foreign
that's a better solution than me giving
up what I'm allowed to read who decides
that who decides what gets the no
evidence for that sticker slapped on it
most people in this country still have a
religion
they believe they have an imaginary best
friend in the sky
who they can talk to to help them with
their problems
nobody throws up a warning label on that
that says there's no evidence for this
now
conservatives do seem to have a special
talent for embracing the real eye roll
stuff like Hillary's pizza parlor
pedophile ring Or democrats eat babies
lizard people are running the world
[Laughter]
but 41 percent of Democrats last year
believe the hospitalization rate if you
got coveted unvaccinated was over 50
percent
when it was actually less than one
percent somebody's misinformation got to
those people
sometimes misinformation is just
history's first draft I see a lot of
things on social media and also on Old
Fox Media
and I don't completely believe any of it
not right away not until I check it out
and when I ask is it true
usually the answer turns out to be well
sort of
or yes but yeah see we've all become
very Adept at saying things that are
technically true but lack context or
that leave out half the story so if
we're going to ban on truth
does that include the half-truth the
quarter truth and wait don't the wokest
people in the world believe that what
really matters is your truth
so yes
of course we should ban Kitty porn and
libel and personal threats and calls for
Insurrection that's a no-brainer because
they're already illegal
just as it would be illegal in an actual
Town Square to whip out your dick
and so should it be in the digital Town
Square
and so should Bots and deep fakes be
banned and anything else that aren't
really the people who say they are but
that's an entirely different thing that
actual people expressing an opinion as
repugnant or offensive or as misguided
as some opinions may be this is still
America
[Music]
where people
[Applause]
where people have the right to express
what they think including to be wrong to
lie and yes the right to be an [ __ ]
and if you think you know everything and
no one else could possibly have some
other truth you should be glad for that
protection because you're an [ __ ]